There's nothing like a good campfire.
The sound, the smells, and the s'mores.
But perhaps what's most special about a campfire are the stories that people tell.
I mean hearing people's stories and listening to others is one of the best ways to
build relationships. Since you're here with me at this campfire let me share a
couple personal stories with you.
Not too long ago I went to a national conference that was a part of a movement
designed to change the church's view of same-sex relationships.
I went there not to rain on anybody's party, but to understand what this movement
was about and just to meet people personally kind of from the inside.
Well, it was like any other conference that I'd been to.
There was worship, there was testimonies, but there were also 90-minute sessions
where the leaders went into depth on some of the biblical passages arguing that the
church has been wrong about same-sex relationships for 2,000 years but when they
were done the head person got up there and said we've assigned each of you at this
conference to go to a small classroom and now you're going to roleplay the talking
points that you've learned so you can go back and have conversations with people
when you get back home well we went to these small classrooms and there's maybe 15
or 20 people there and I sat down kind of in a shape of a U like two rows facing
up at the front board and the lady went to the front and she said we're gonna practice
these talking points but before doing so I think it'd be great if each person went
around in the room and shared why you're here at this conference and why you're so
passionate about this movement I remember sitting there thinking I didn't sign up
for this what do I say what would you say if you were in that same situation now I
disagreed with the other people in the room but some of the stories were
heartbreaking about people who came out to their parents and were kicked out of
their home and so finally they came to me and I said hi my name is Sean McDowell and
I teach at Biola University and they're kind of look at me I said well if you know
Biola you know that I'm probably not theologically where you'd want me to be but I
want to read you something and they passed out to everybody at the conference which
had about three or four hundred people they've given all of us these packets and on
the front it said something effective you are welcome here you are loved and
accepted here. No matter where you are on your journey, you are loved here.
And I read it to him. I said, does this apply to me?
I said, you know, I'm not here to rain on anybody's party.
You and I actually have a lot in common.
We believe that what Jesus said about the issue of sexuality and relationships is
important. We believe what the Bible says about this is important.
Although we differ over some of the particulars, you and I actually have a lot in
common but i want you to know something the narrative is that people like me who
believe the traditional view about sexuality are hateful bigoted and homophobic
i just want you to know that that's not always true in fact i care about and love
each one of you that are in this room
the reality is that today we find ourselves in these difficult situations where we
feel the tension between speaking truth but acting in love my guess is you've
probably found yourself in a similar situation but remember what Jesus always did is
he always spoke truth he never compromised what was true because he knew it was the
truth that would set people free but he always spoke that truth with graciousness
and with love in contrast to this first story let me tell you about a time when
i blew it my senior year in college i took a class on apologetics i was ready and
anxious to have a conversation with anybody who wanted to talk with me about
spiritual things well shortly after graduation i was up in the mountains and i went
to get my hair cut and as i sat down in the shop i was holding a book that dealt
with spiritual issues and the lady who's gonna cut my hair she was maybe 25 or 30
years old i remember she said to me she goes, oh, is that a book on spiritual
issues? Do you mind if I ask you some questions?
And I remember thinking, yes. I just took a class on apologetics.
Bring it on. I'm ready with an answer.
So I sit down and she says to me, she says, you know, I've always wondered if God is
so good and powerful, how can there be so much evil and suffering in the world?
And instantly, I remember thinking, that's all you got?
This is easy. So I launched into it.
I said, you know, your question about evil assumes there's good.
And if there's good, there must be a God.
I said, besides God doesn't want us to be robots.
I gave the free will defense. She had another question.
I was ready with a response. In my mind, things were going fantastic until all
of a sudden she steps back. She starts to cry and she says, you have an answer for
everything. It can't be this simple.
And it kind of made me nervous to be honest, because she's shaking and she's holding
scissors to my head. So I changed the subject, gave her a big tip when we left.
We go walking outside and I said to my friend who was there with me, I said, man,
what's up with her? We're having a great conversation.
And she starts to cry. And he stops and looks at me right in the eyes and he says,
Sean, do you have any idea how arrogant you were towards her?
And friends, it hit me like a ton of bricks and I realized that I was far
more concerned in winning an argument, I was far more concerned in sounding smart
than in really loving her and treating her as a human being.
That was one of the first times in my life that my eyes were really open.
I realized if I have all the answers and I have truth but I don't have love, I have
nothing.
This lesson is not really about the biblical position on homosexuality or solving
the problem of evil. It's not really about any particular issue at all.
Rather, it's about speaking the truth in love.
As followers of Christ, we need to have the courage to speak truth and to speak it
boldly. But not arrogantly as I did to the lady who was cutting my hair, but do it
out of compassion. Do it with a heart of graciousness and kindness towards those who
need the truth to set them free.
In Matthew 18:21-35, Jesus tells the story of the unmerciful servant.
Here is a servant who was forgiven a massive sum from the king.
But then he turns around and demands that another servant who owes him just a few
dollars pay him back. Now why was this servant so demanding and didn't show
forgiveness to the other servant?
it's because he failed to truly understand and appreciate how much the king had
forgiven him.
I think sometimes we fail to really show grace and love to other people because we
don't really understand the depth of sin in our own hearts and understand how much
God has forgiven us. If we really want to be able to love people the way God wants
us to love them, it begins by first understanding how much God has loved us.
If you are willing to speak truth boldly, but do it from a heart motivated
by love. And if you're willing to listen to other people's stories because you care
about them and also willing to share yours, I really believe that God could use you
to do powerful things within your generation.